bonsoir à toutes et tous avez vous
remarqué combien le futur s'est
rapproché de nous moi c'est ma nièce
élise qui me l'a fait remarquer un soir
où elle n'arrivait pas à dormir je vais
raconter l'histoire de minority report
en espérant que ces voitures qui se
conduisent toute seules que les cellules
de police qui prédisent des crimes
allez la faire rêver et en réalité elle
a trouvé ça super banal comme si le
monde qui avait imaginé philip k.dick
pour 2050
en fait on l'avait déjà réalisé en 2017
et j'avais l'impression alors que élisez
moi on n'avait pas du tout la même
conception du temps que là où j'étais
presque persuadé que le temps était
toujours quelque chose de linéaire que
le présent et est la conséquence du
passé et la cause d'un futur
j'avais l'impression que pour elle tout
se passait comme si le temps couler du
futur pour venir provoquer le présent se
superposer à lui s'y confondre et donc
2050 c'est bien 2017 alors élise m'a
demandé bon c'est sympa ton qui pique
ton histoire là mais il ya quoi après
moi j'étais très gêné parce que je ne
connais pas la suite de minority report
je crois pas qu'il y en ai donc je me
dis je sais pas écoute imagine me dit
mais non il ya quoi
après le futur et depuis c'est moi qui
ne dort plus parce que c'est une
question extraordinaire que personne ne
se pose quand le futur est déjà là parce
que notre imagination est saturé d'une
science fiction qui radotent et qui va
quelque part moins vite que le réel
alors concevoir le temps toujours comme
quelque chose de linéaire fait que en
voulant aller toujours tout droit et
plus vite
tout se passe comme si on courait sur un
tapis roulant
c'est à dire qu'on fait du surplace et à
vrai dire même une des innovations les
plus extraordinaires de notre époque
hyper loupe témoigne bien que pour aller
toujours plus vite
il faut aller toujours tout droit aller
à la vitesse du son certes mais dans un
tunnel aveugle qui empêche de regarder
d'autres voies possibles aller toujours
plus vite mais ne jamais créer deux
destinations nouvelles surtout pas au
contraire connecter des villes qui
existe déjà et en tuant la distance
rétrécir le monde alors on a
l'impression que dans l'illusion de
l'innovation sous le progrès face à
l'obsolescence programmée
nous accélérons mais sans transformer le
monde vraiment plus tôt en le répétant
toujours un peu plus vite
d'autant que notre génération est
confrontée à une autre accélération
celle de l'intelligence des machines est
le seul futur qu'on nous promet c'est
celui de la singularité ce moment où
nous tous finalement seront dépassés par
des intelligences de machines et où pour
survivre
nous n'aurons d'autre choix que de
fusionner avec elle super futur qu'on
nous promettait avec un futuriste comme
récurent revel pour 2045 et mauvaise
nouvelle il s'est finalement ravisé
ça se rapproche c'est pour 2029 alors
comme on essaye toujours d'accélérer
encore cette seule histoire on construit
des robots qui nous ressemblent des
miroirs de nous-mêmes avec deux bras
deux jambes quand cats seraient plus
efficaces mais tout va bien parce qu'ils
peuvent reprendre exactement les
activités qu'on avait déjà donc
forcément quand j'interroge une jeune
génération de chercheurs sur leur futur
avec l'intelligence artificielle 90%
d'entre eux l'envoi l'image de
terminator fantastique moment où on
réalise que finalement eux mêmes ont
l'impression de programmer leur propre
sol et sens de ne pas oser raconté
chercher une autre histoire
et étrangement on a l'impression
effectivement que la prophétie se
réalise que nous nous rapprochons des
machines moins vrai dire parce que les
machines sont de plus en plus
intelligentes que parce qu'en réalité
est parfois grâce à elle nous devenons
de plus en plus cons comme avec ce
formidable jeu faith dance que je
conseille quand même à tous ceux qui
jouent régulièrement
tout se passe comme si nous simulons une
machine qui nous stimule pour gagner des
points
alors c'est sûr nous nous dirigeons vers
un futur singulier celui d'une vie de
machines là où tout converge et alors il
ya quoi après ce futur ya rien il ya la
fin finalement de l'humanité telle qu'on
la connaît aujourd'hui et il ya ce que
récursive à l'appel l'inimaginable
pourtant je veux croire que lorsque l'on
arrive au bout du segment là où le futur
et le présent se rencontrent nous avons
une opportunité extraordinaire non pas
de tomber dans la peur ou de continuer à
courir sur place étouffé par des techno
gadget mais bien à sortir de la flèche
du temps pour ouvrir l'éventail des
futurs possibles
alors pour le faire il faudra les
réinventer avec audace penser les futurs
plus humain ne plus chercher à seulement
accélérer une seule ligne mais bien
pensé tous ces futurs possibles pour les
distribuer équitablement dans notre
monde et alors on le comprend
ce ne sera pas un travail d'intelligence
convergentes de puissance de calcul mais
bien un devoir d'imagination pour penser
la pluralité plutôt que la singularité
il va falloir le faire tous ensemble
l'avantagent c'est que quelqu'un l'a
déjà fait et c'est pas elon musk mais
léonard de vinci
cet homme à l'imagination débordante que
ses contemporains pense est venu du
futur parce qu'il imaginait des projets
comme des bateaux volants que l'on ne
saurait réalisé que quelques décennies
plus tard mais en réalité son
imagination elle était nourrie par des
connaissances véritable dans les
sciences les arts les humanités et c'est
à leur intersection
qu'ils pouvaient innover vraiment
radicalement le problème c'est que après
léonard de vinci le monde
en s'ouvrant s'est complexifiée à tel
point que personne aujourd'hui ne peut
prétendre tout connaître
peut-être que c'est là la plus grande
opportunité de l'intelligence
artificielle nous permettent de
transformer le chaos d'information
alentours en connaissance actionnable
pour mieux comprendre le monde et agir
différemment sur lui alors nous
penserions des intelligences
artificielles qui ouvre des voies
plurielle qui nous augmente
au lieu de nous réduire à la machine par
exemple le design génératif transforme
complètement aujourd'hui le travail d'un
créateur là où vous deviez pour dessiner
un drone en pensée 2 3 le coucher sur le
papier avant de le réaliser
vous pouvez désormais sur ce logiciel
rentrée les paramètres de vol de votre
engin
la machine va vous en proposer des
milliers de possibilités parmi lesquels
vous pourrez choisir lequel vous
faudrait réaliser le dessinateur est
passé quelques parts de créateur à
curateur son imagination et comme
augmenté par la machine mais
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
aussi nous permettre d'organiser de
compléter nos intelligences collectives
vous savez depuis 2012 sur minecraft des
hordes de joueurs ça faire en ligne à
simuler des villes existantes pour y
tester de nouveaux projets et si
aujourd'hui nous complétions cette
intelligence d'une intelligence
artificielle qui pourrait apprendre de
ces comportements et permettent ensemble
de multiplier ces mondes mais surtout
pour de grands problèmes mal définis
dans notre humanité chercher à résoudre
dans des mondes parallèles des solutions
trouver les solutions que nous irons
rattraper pour les réaliser ici même
alors ensemble nous construirons une
intelligence artificielle plurielle et
courons vers la pluralité qui divergent
et augmente mais finalement il ya quoi
après le futur ce qui est sûr c'est que
aujourd'hui on ne se pose pas la
question parce qu'on est bien à ces
obsédés par le futur lui même et sa
vitesse
et à vrai dire ce n'est pas la première
fois
parce que petit aparté on est tombé dans
ce piège il ya un siècle déjà
vous savez le futurisme italien avait
promis que pour ouvrir grand les portes
de la nouveauté
il fallait accélérer toujours plus vite
sur la même ligne droite brûlés le passé
courir au futur et sur le chemin
évidemment converger au surhomme mais
après leur futur il n'y avait que la
justification de l'eugénisme ignoble de
l'époque
pourtant quelques décennies plus tard un
autre mouvement littéraire celui ci
propose et non pas d'accélérer sur la
ligne du temps mais d'en sortir pour
créer des mondes
c'était le réalisme magique qui ne
voyait pas dans l'intelligence
artillerie mène quelque chose de
fantastique mais qui pensaient au
contraire que le monde était dur et
d'une âme et que chaque partie du monde
était intelligente différemment alors à
notre époque où l'on croit qu'il suffit
de connecter un stylo avec son frigo à
sa voiture au feu rouge suffit à rendre
la ville intelligente peut être que
renouer avec cette animisme n'ont pas de
l'ignorance mais de la connaissance nous
permettra d'explorer des intelligences
pluriel déjà chez les humains en dehors
dans la nature
pourquoi pas tout simplement autres à
humaine aliens qui nous permettrait de
considérer des intelligences
véritablement complémentaires des nôtres
pour mieux comprendre le monde
l'explorer en créer de nouveaux et
peut-être avoir une nouvelle conception
du temps parce que vous savez à
l'échelle du cosmos
il y a peu de temps encore les humains
considérés en regardant la ligne droite
de l'horizon que la terre était plate
et si aujourd'hui nous nous trompions
encore non plus dans notre conception de
l'espace mais du temps
si demain n'était pas seulement la suite
logique d'aujourd'hui et si nous
pouvions confié à notre imagination
le devoir de penser tous les futurs pour
aller chercher collectivement
celui que l'on veut réaliser et
rétrospectivement à rebours depuis ce
futur choisir celui
que l'on construira dès aujourd'hui
alors nous ferions ensemble non plus du
futur une fin mais des futurs un moyen
au service du présent et de son avenir
alors élise il ya quoi
après le futur j'espère que c'est toi
qui pourra répondre à cette question
pour nous montrer un jour quelques
années qu après le futur il y avait bien
deux meilleurs présent
[Applaudissements]